[MUSIC PLAYING]
HIDEAKI OSHIMA: Hi, everybody.
Thank you for joining us today.
My name is Hideaki
Oshima, and I'm
the product manager on the
Android Authentication team
here at Google.
And we are here today to
talk about best practices
for getting your users
signed into your Android app.
So let's dive straight in.
Now, as I'm sure
you're all aware,
user authentication can
be a complex problem.
There are lots of different
solutions out there,
and it can get very confusing
very quickly, especially
from the user's perspective.
Now, let's imagine
your user, or a user,
goes and downloads an app and
is taken to this sign-in page.
Now, at the top
of the page, they
might see buttons to sign in
using a federated identity
provider.
And, at this point, the
user might be wondering, hm,
what are these buttons?
Have I used them before?
Can I trust them?
And as a user makes their
way further down the page,
now they might see the classic
username and password entry
fields.
And, at this point, if the
user is anything like me,
they're probably realizing
that they completely
forgot their credentials.
Ultimately, if
this were your app,
your user might go through a
password or account recovery
flow, which could be
costly for you guys,
or they might end up
creating and signing up
with a brand new
account, which could lead
to a loss of user data and,
ultimately or possibly,
less user engagement.
Worse yet, you might end up
losing that user entirely.
So as you think through
the sign-in problem,
you're probably wondering
which of the different options
you should be offering
to your users.
As I mentioned in
the previous slide,
you can allow your user to sign
in using a federated identity
provider such as Google.
You can also offer the classic
username and password option.
You can also allow users to
sign up using their phone number
or sign in using biometrics.
And it's not just sign-in that
you're worried about, right?
Once your users
are signed in, you
want to make sure that both
your users and your app
are protected from
account abuse.
You also want to make
sure your users can
easily and securely submit
their payment information.
So with all of the
different things
that you have to consider,
you might be asking yourself,
so where do I start?
What are all of the things
that I should be considering
as I design and develop my app?
So our objective for today
is to provide guidance
on the following questions.
Number one, how do I simplify
the onboarding process
for my users?
Number two, once my
users are signed in,
how do I facilitate
payment transactions?
And number three, how do
I prevent account abuse?
And as we walk through
these questions today,
we want to make sure that we
keep the end customer user
journey in mind, because
as I'm sure we all agree,
that's what's most important.
And we want to make sure that
we do our best to put you guys
in a position to be successful.
So now I'm going to
hand it off to Carlos,
who's going to talk about
the onboarding process.
CARLOS VALDIVIA:
Thanks, Hideaki.
My name is Carlos, and I lead
the account authentication,
management, and security
efforts within Android.
And I'm here today to
talk to you about both
getting your users into your
app and having them authenticate
well as well as to sort
of keep them in your app.
Specifically, I'm
going to talk to you
about Google Sign-In, Google
Smart Lock for passwords,
as well as Autofill with Google.
I should note that
I'm not going to work
through any sort of
code examples here,
but at the end of
the presentation,
we'll have a slide
with a bunch of links
that are sort of links
to the relevant developer
documentation.
Google Sign-In provides the
simplest onboarding as well as
reboarding experience
for your users.
It is one tap to get
your users on board.
And subsequent sign-ins from
the user either on the web,
or on Android, or
on iOS devices,
it's completely automatic.
And it also provides the best
security story for your users.
As Google sort of provides
more services to users
to be able to prevent
phishing, et cetera,
you'll benefit from that if
your users are Google-signed-in.
The Doodle app, which does
meetings and sort of meeting
organization, it saw
substantial improvement
when they went over
to the Google Sign-In
for their initial registrations.
If you're unable to do
client-side and server-side
integrations, then Google Smart
Lock may be your best bet.
It's only a client-side
integration.
And what it allows you
to do is programmatically
integrate with a store of
usernames and passwords
that are managed by Google.
Those passwords are also used
for Chrome password management
as well as for Autofill.
And with this, you
can sort of have
your users go through a
traditional sign-in flow,
but when they
subsequently re-sign in,
it can just be
completely automatic.
You just programmatically
get the password,
you don't need to show a
username or password prompt,
and it's a fantastic
user experience.
Netflix, as a
result of this, has
seen a substantial reduction
in contacts with their users
when they're asking for
help, because they forgot
their usernames and passwords.
Finally, if you're unable to
do any substantial integration
on the client side,
Autofill with Google
is our attempt to help your
users get into your apps.
It's available on Oreo+ devices.
About 45% of those
users are opted in.
And we're filling millions
of passwords every day.
And how it works,
again, is that your app
is in front of the user, it's
showing a username and password
field, we do our best
integrating with the framework
to be able to detect
that field and make
a suggestion to the user about
what the right sign-in is.
In all of these cases,
there are things that you
can do to help us help you.
Specifically, if you're
going to use Google Sign-In
or you're going to use
Smart Lock for passwords,
you can register your app with
the Google Developer Console.
This will help Google
tell us what your app is,
and it helps with quota, and
it's just a necessary feature
of using those APIs.
In addition, I want to suggest
that you also set up Digital
Asset Links with your apps.
If you have a
presence on the web
and a presence on
an Android app,
it really helps us reuse
passwords between the two
for both Smart
Lock for passwords
and for Autofill with Google.
And how you do that is you just
have your domain serve an Asset
Link file, and then you make
a declaration in your Android
manifest.
Again, there will be a link at
the end of the presentation.
So to summarize,
Google Sign-In--
one tap to get your users on.
And then it's just
automatic afterwards.
Well, programmatic for you,
but automatic for your users.
And it works on all
Android operating systems.
It works on iOS.
It works on the web.
Smart Lock for passwords?
There will be a manual
onboarding process,
but once you programmatically
integrate with it,
it means that subsequent
sign-ins by your users
will work on all
Android devices.
And it's, again, auto-magical.
Finally, Autofill
with Google will
allow you to have your
users get back into your app
with suggested usernames
and passwords from Google.
And that will make
it much easier
to get your users back
on board with identities
that you are already aware of.
And it's available on
Oreo+ Android phones.
Finally, if you're going
to be using phone number
verification--
for example, it's
very common for apps
to use OTPs to verify
their user's identity--
there will be policy changes
coming in the future.
Traditionally, apps have
taken the SMS permission
or the call logs permission.
But the Play Store is changing
their policies regarding this,
and those apps that take
those permissions are going
to get a lot more scrutiny.
So we suggest that you take
a look at the Google Play
Services' SMS Retriever API.
It allows you to
programmatically integrate
with the Google Play Services.
And what will happen
is that you'll still
send an SMS message
to the phone,
but Google Play Services
will mediate that message,
and you will only get your OTP.
The benefit of this
is that you don't
need to ask your users
for scary permissions
to still be able to verify
their phone numbers.
And Flipkart,
using this API, has
found a substantial
increase in sign-up.
To reiterate, don't ask
for tons of permissions,
especially if they're
not directly related
to your business case.
We live in a climate where users
are very privacy-sensitive.
And asking for lots of
extraneous permissions
that aren't clearly
and obviously related
to your business case is
a recipe for problems.
So part of the
onboarding flow is also
keeping your users onboard when
they eventually switch devices.
And a lot of what I've
talked about already
is relevant to that case, where
a user leaves their old device,
they move to a new device.
Google Sign-In, Smart
Lock for passwords,
they will just smoothly
have your users transfer
their identity from
one phone to the other
because it'll just be portable.
When you do have an
app, we do suggest
that you test to make sure
that Autofill with Google
is correctly identifying your
usernames and your passwords.
Help us help you.
In addition, add
recovery options
for your usernames
and passwords.
It's very common,
in an Android app,
as Hideaki mentioned,
for a user to only enter
their username once and only
enter their password once
and then, two or
three years later,
have no idea what that password
is when they get a new device.
So, if you add recovery
options, you're
going to increase the chances
of keeping your users.
Finally, Google does
provide a backup
and restore service
to our users.
And the benefit of that is that
it also backs up and restores
app data, including your data.
So test to make sure that
that's working properly for you
and that you can get the
most value out of that.
And it should make that
transition from one device
to another as smooth as
possible for the user
and ensure that you get the
most value from your user
re-engagement on a new phone.
Next, Jay is going to talk about
how to facilitate payments.
JAY CIVELLI: Thank you, Carlos.
Hi.
My name is Jay Civelli,
and I'm a software engineer
on the Autofill
with Google team.
So Carlos talked
about how we can
improve the log-in experience.
I'd like to talk about how we
can make the payment experience
better for our users.
Making a payment
on a mobile device
can be quite a tedious task.
You have to get your
physical credit card,
enter a bunch of numbers
on a soft keyboard.
It's error-prone, it's tedious,
and, if you're like me,
chances are you've
been in a situation
where you've given up on making
a transaction just because
of that, the pain, because that
process was just too painful.
So what can we do?
The best thing you can do
to make transaction payments
easier into your application is
integrate with the Google Pay
APIs.
They provide a seamless
checkout experience for users,
and there is a best way to
get your users checked out.
So how does that work?
You basically provide--
integrate with Google Pay APIs.
You have a Google Pay
button in your app.
When the user
presses that button,
they're presented
with the credit
card, debit cards available
on their Google account.
And they can easily
check out by selecting
one of those accounts.
Actually, we've seen,
for instance, [INAUDIBLE]
conversion rate increase by
65% when they transitioned
to those Google Pay APIs.
So that's really
what we recommend.
Something to keep in
mind-- that there's
kind of an investment to getting
integrated with these APIs.
You have to integrate with
the entire flow of the API
and with your payment
service providers.
So if you're not yet
ready to do that work,
something else you
can do is make sure
that Autofill works great
with your app, something
that Carlos mentioned already.
So Autofill is not just
about username and passwords.
It can actually help with
many of the scenarios
like credit cards, names, first
name, last name, phone numbers,
email addresses,
physical addresses.
So anything that's tedious
to enter into an application,
Autofill can help.
So here we can see how
it works with payments.
We are in an app, and the
user tapped on the Credit Card
field.
And what Autofill
provides-- it shows
you that dropdown with
a credit card that's
available in the Google
account of the user.
The user can select
that dropdown
to autofill that credit
card into their form.
So that's actually used.
We see millions of payments
forms filled with Autofill
every week.
So that's definitely something
that brings value to the user.
Something you might be
wondering is, how does Autofill
know, when I tap on
a Credit Card field,
that this is actually
a Credit Card field?
And so the way it works is
that Autofill Services will
use a bunch of heuristics
or other techniques,
and they will extract
data from the views
to figure out what
that field is.
But, if you want to make
sure Autofill gets it
right 100% of the time,
there's something fairly easy
you can do.
And this is using
Autofill Hints.
So here we have a code
snippet of a layout XML file.
And you can see there's
a TextView in there.
And what we've done is that
we've tagged that TextView
with the AUTOFILL
HINT, and we've
tagged it with the
creditCardNumber, AUTOFILL
HINT.
What does that do?
It basically tells the
Autofill service provider
that this field
is a credit card.
So there's no guessing involved
by the Autofill service,
and it will show the
right suggestion.
So you might also be wondering,
where does that credit card
number come from?
It's actually a constant found
in the Android View class.
If you go and take
a look in there,
you'll see that there's
a bunch of those hints.
They use the
AUTOFILL HINT prefix.
So those Autofill
hints have been
added in Android O when
the Autofill capability was
introduced in Android.
But we found out that
they're not always
as granular as user may want.
For instance, if
you look at Name,
there's only one hint for names.
There's no distinction between
first name and last name.
For that reason,
we're introducing soon
Extended Autofill Hints.
So those new hints will be
included in the Compatibility
library, and it will
give you more control
over all different kind
of things you may want
to have in your application.
So I was talking about names.
You see we have now
a greater breakdown
of all the different names you
could have in your app as well
as addresses and other types.
So we saw how you can
actually help Autofill suggest
the right thing in your app.
However, there are cases
where you actually don't want
Autofill to suggest anything.
Imagine you have an app
where you have an activity
to add friends with
their phone numbers.
So that activity would
have only one field,
which is Phone Number.
When the user taps
that field, Autofill
might detect it as a phone
number, but in that case,
we obviously don't want
to suggest a phone number
as a user's phone
number, because it
is forwarding somebody else.
So in those cases where
you don't want Autofill
to do any suggestion, you can
actually turn off Autofill
by tagging the field with the
Imported for Autofill property.
So you see in that snippet
here there is a text view.
And it's being tagged with
Imported for Autofill, No.
What does that do?
That instructs the
Autofill service,
please ignore that
view entirely.
And so you can use that to
disable one field or more.
And actually, if you have
more than one field--
let's say, in our
previous example,
in that Add Friend
activity, if you
had multiple fields with
first name, last name, email,
and you want to
disable all of them,
you can actually set that
Imported for Autofill property
on a parent node and you set
it with no exclude descendants.
And what that does is that it
excludes all the nodes located
under that specific node.
So, to recap, what
we suggest you
do if you want Autofill
to work great in your app
is to go through your
layout XML files.
And, every time you
have an input field,
make sure it's either disabled
if it doesn't make sense
to have it enabled or it
specifies the right types,
Autofill works all the time.
So that's one aspect of
the payment experience.
We want to be able to suggest
and to make it easy for users
to enter their credit
card information.
There's another
thing that comes up.
It's related to OTPs.
And so, in markets like
India, for instance,
every time you make a
purchase online or in an app,
you have to provide
an OTP provided
by your financial institution.
So, as Carlos talked about,
we could use the SMS Retriever
app.
We can use two
[INAUDIBLE] the SMS
Retriever app to retrieve OTPs.
But this is restricted to
OTPs you send yourself.
In those kind of
scenarios, those OTPs
are sent by a
third party, so you
don't have control over
who's sending that.
In the past, you would
probably have used the SMS read
permission to actually read
the SMS as they come in
and try to find
that OTP yourself.
But as Carlos, the Play
Store policy is changing
and we now are trying
to help developers not
get access to all the SMS from
the user for privacy reasons.
So we're introducing
another API, which
is the SMS User Consent API.
What that API does is
that it will let you still
access third-party
OTPs, but we will
prompt the user to
make sure they agree
of providing you that OTP.
So let's take a look
at how it works.
Here we have Zomato, which
is one of our partner apps.
And they are using the API.
Let's see what they do.
So first of all,
you start the app.
At this point, it
requires an OTP.
It's going to call the SMS
Retriever, Start SMS Retriever
Consent API.
What that does is that
it instructs the SMS User
Consent to start
paying attention
for SMS messages coming in
with potential OTPs in them.
Once an SMS message
with an OTP comes in,
the Consent API will
actually send a broadcast
to your application,
and that broadcast
will contain consent intent
that it can extract out
of the broadcast.
And you will have to
start that consent intent
with startActivityForResult.
What does it do?
It will show that dialogue
you're seeing there
at the bottom of the screen,
and this will show two things
to the user.
First of them, it will tell them
which app is requiring access
to the SMS.
And, second, it will actually
list the content of the SMS.
The user will then be
able to see clearly
what it's given to the app.
Once it click Allow,
then in your app,
you will, on the
Activity Result,
get the actual SMS
message as part
of the data intent provided
on the activity result.
So you can then extract the
SMS message, parse the OTP,
and use it in your application.
So, to recap, when it comes
to automated SMS verification,
you have two options.
The first option is
using SMS Retriever API.
That means you have
access to the back end.
You're sending data actual SMS.
This is a preferred API
to use in that case,
because no user
consent is required.
The experience is
pretty seamless.
No interaction from the user.
If you don't have
access to the back end,
if it's a third-party
OTP, then you
want to use the SMS Consent API.
So in that case, you can use
it in any kind of scenario,
but user will have
to give permission
for every message you receive
that your app needs to consume.
And there will be one tap
involved in that case.
And with that, I'm
going to hand it over
to Steven, who's going
to talk about how
to prevent account abuse.
STEVEN SONEFF: OK.
Thanks very much, Jay.
So my name is Steven.
I'm a product manager
here at Google
working on authentication
and security.
So in this last
section, we're going
to talk about another problem
that comes up for developers.
Eventually, after improving
your onboarding flows
and helping users do
things in your apps,
you'll inevitably run
into the problem of abuse.
So we're going to cover a
couple different categories.
The first is about the creation
of illegitimate accounts.
So you might have
encountered this
before as you build an app.
You'll have people,
often through automation,
trying to create
accounts at scale.
And there's a variety
of different tools
that you are able to use to
help mitigate this problem.
So one of the first
ones that we recommend
is using a trusted identity
provider for your users.
So encouraging people
to go through something
like a Sign-In with Google flow.
And the opportunity,
the advantage
here is that these identity
providers, like Google,
have done a lot of
checks on their users.
So in the case of
Google accounts,
when someone creates
a new Google account,
we look for all forms of
automation, try to detect that
and stop these
accounts from being
created in the first place.
So what you can do as an
application developer is
when you see someone come in
with a Google Sign-In account,
you will know that this
person has been through checks
from Google.
And you're getting
those for free
by just having a
user use these flows.
Beyond that, of course,
people may sign up
with other mechanisms.
And things like verifying
users' phone numbers
or forms of payments can
be additional signals
that you look at to
try to mitigate abuse
from these types of
account creation.
Now, the thing to
keep in mind here
is that adding checks on
people's phone numbers
or forms of payment
introduce additional friction
into the onboarding flows you're
trying to build for users,
so you have to use
them really carefully.
And there's the tools, like
Carlos mentioned earlier,
the SMS Retriever that can
help you verify something
like a phone number more
easily by automatically
reading the contents of an SMS
that contains a one-time code.
So keep that in mind when
you're building flows
where you have to verify
additional user information.
And, finally, there
are APIs on Android
that help you detect and
prevent the usage of your app
through automated mechanisms
like scripts and bots.
And let's go into a little
bit of detail about those two.
So the first one here
is the Safety Net API.
And so the Safety Net
API will help give you
an assertion, or an attestation,
that the user of your app
is on a legitimate, real device.
How this works is in
calling a Play Services API,
you can ask the device to
collect a bunch of information,
send that to Google, and have
Google analyze and determine
the integrity of this
device, whether it's real,
that the OS is intact, and so
on, and return this assertion
back to your app.
Once you have this
information, you
can send it to your own
server and then use it
as a signal in
your own onboarding
flows you have
positive reinforcement
that this is, in fact,
a legitimate device.
So if you think about
it, when someone
is trying to create
accounts at scale,
it becomes really
expensive when they
have to have real devices in
order to create those accounts.
But sometimes having a
real device isn't enough.
And there's another
option here, which
is to put a ReCAPTCHA
flow into your apps.
Now, again, this is one that
you want to use judiciously,
because people will
potentially run
into this when they
are legitimate users
and this is going to
add additional friction
for those users.
So keep in mind that
this should only
be used when you
really need it, when
you have an indication that
this is a risky transaction
or that there is some
form of abuse that
has happened in the past.
OK.
With that, you have
hopefully created
an account that's legitimate.
And the next problem that
you'll have to go through
is keeping that account safe,
so preventing bad actors
from accessing this account,
and stealing user data,
performing transactions
that could be harmful
to the users of your apps.
So for this, you can use
several of the technologies
that we've already mentioned.
The first one that
we brought up earlier
was using Google Sign-In and
a trusted identity provider.
And this is a great
opportunity, because Google
does so many checks when
people activate their Google
accounts on an Android device.
You've probably
encountered this yourself--
that we do things like
send notifications
on a new sign-in event, allow
users to go into their account
settings and audit where
their account is active,
and look at a multitude
of signals about where
this event is happening, the
history of the device that you
can leverage as a developer
by simply having someone
go through a Google Sign-In
flow and have those signals when
they're accessing an
account and your service.
There's actually an
interesting new feature
that came out recently
called Cross Account
protection, where, if you've
had a user sign in with a Google
account into your
service, you can
subscribe for notifications
on security events related
to that account.
So for example, if this user's
account is hijacked at Google,
you'll know about that and can
help them secure their account
with your service.
So a trusted identity provider
is one place to start with,
but, of course,
there are people who
are going to sign up without
using an identity provider.
And for those users, you may
want to add additional steps
in the verification flows.
So that's things like sending
them a one-time code via SMS
or some sort of
a time-based flow
to get additional
signals that it's them
and prevent and/or combat
the problem of password
reuse or weak passwords.
So there, again, this is adding
friction potentially for users,
so you'll want to use the
APIs like SMS Retriever
to try to mitigate and
ease these flows for users,
so that they don't have to
enter this information manually.
But keep in mind, if you
saw the talk that was just
happening before this
on protecting users
from deception, that there
is, in fact, another problem
here, which is phishing.
So even with the use of
one-time codes over SMS,
we find that it's very common
that when a user encounters
a malicious site that's asking
them for this information,
they will happily enter that
into this malicious phishing
website or app.
So to combat that, we've been
working with the FIDO Alliance
to introduce APIs on Android
that provide resistance
to phishing.
And so these are APIs that
allow you, as a developer,
to talk to the authentication
hardware built in on Android,
so things like biometric sensors
or external security keys,
and use that information to help
mitigate against the phishing
problem.
Now, there's a couple
of different flows
that this supports.
So for example, imagine you
have a user coming to your app,
logging in for the first
time, and then enrolling
a fingerprint.
You can really easily
check that it's
that person when they come
back, using this flow known
as Local User Verification.
Furthermore, you can support
this cross-device usage
where someone comes
back on another device
and, having enrolled a
security key or some sort
of external
authenticator previously,
check that it's them
on this new one.
So there's a couple
different flows
that you can support here.
And there's a few things that
you really should keep in mind.
So the first is
about biometrics.
The biometrics on Android
never leave the device.
So what happens is, when someone
enrolls their fingerprint,
they're just locally
setting up the information
such that secure keys can
be released to the app
or signature-produced from
them that you could then
send to your server.
The biometrics themselves don't
actually leave the device.
And the second is that
this phishing resistance
is provided by a couple
of different properties.
One is that the
authenticator in question
here is either built into the
device or physically nearby.
And the fact then that this
credential, these keys that I
mentioned, which are unlocked,
are only provided to your app
signed with your
developer sign-in keys
or to an associated website.
And so one thing that you can
do today when you get home
is check that the
association has
been set up between your
app and your website.
As Carlos mentioned
earlier, that
enables password sharing between
a native app and a website.
And it will also support this
phishing-resistant log-in flows
with FIDO credentials.
So that's the
tricks that you can
employ in your app to get
people signed in more securely.
And I'm going to hand
it back to Hideaki
to wrap up and give you some
links for all the information
we've shown today.
HIDEAKI OSHIMA: Not yet.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So, to wrap up, we want to
make sure we minimize friction
for users at each step
of the customer journey.
So step 1, we want to offer
seamless sign-up and sign-in
by using Google Sign-In,
Smart Lock for passwords,
or Autofill Hints
for credentials.
We also want to automate
the OTP verification
process by utilizing
the SMS Retriever API.
Next, we want to simplify the
checkout process for our users
by utilizing the Google
Pay API or Autofill
Hints for payment information.
We also want to streamline
the OTP verification process
from financial institutions by
utilizing the SMS User Consent
API.
And finally, we want to make
sure we consider security
at each step by
utilizing, again,
Google Sign-In, our
Safety Net APIs,
multi-factor authentication,
and/or our FIDO APIs.
And if you want
more information,
you can always refer
to our developer pages.
You can also visit our sandbox
session tomorrow afternoon
from 12:30 to 4:30 PM in
the Android platform area.
And I'm going to
pause for a sec,
so you guys can take
notes, take photos.
All right.
And thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]